here we got to talk about the Great
Gatsby Gatsby Gatsby the Great Gatsby
the Leonardo DiCaprio movie that we just
solved oh my god talk about that why
because last week we said we were going
to talk about iron hand three and you
derailed the conversation like you
usually do and people were upset that we
didn't actually talk about the movie you
want to talk about Iron Man 3 and we can
do it well suck balls I thought you said
you liked it you said it was awesome
that was before I actually saw it listen
the twist is terrible pepper does some
ridiculous and for the second Iron Man
movie in a row there's like almost no
icing I think the ship has sailed on the
Iron Man 3 conversation okay the people
won't want to tune in to it Great Gatsby
conversation and hear us talk about Iron
Man 3 and just the cycle will continue
on and on we got to talk about the Great
Gatsby climb up on the same problem I
had last week I don't want to spoil a
movie for these people well opening day
there are ways to talk about a movie
without spoiling ok like why don't you
just name something that you liked
okay why don't you try naming something
that you didn't like probably easier for
you that's a lot easier all right start
with its to faithful to the book to be
from the book to to big book
how's that pause that literature taken
more liberties to faithful to the book I
don't even think I've ever heard of that
I didn't know that I'm you ever read The
Great Gatsby well yeah but it was a long
time ago I don't really remember it very
well you know consider yourself lucky
born
dude it's a classic yeah classically
boring this is the least exciting book
ever
it's the Mad Men of books all right it
may be brilliant but it's too slow have
the attention span of a five-year-old
all right what else didn't you like
anything else
Tobey Maguire narrow edge the whole
freedom moving well all right this is
what you do when you try and film a book
that's in the first-person with tons of
narration and you realize all I'm gonna
do lots of voiceover alright why not
just film Tobey Maguire the actor
sitting on a stool reading the book and
call it a day right because that would
be entertaining for everyone right build
a movie as Peter Parker reads the great
geyser Garfield is Peter Parker not
talking Maguire that's like the one
thing the new spider-man movies got
running all right did you at least like
Leonardo DiCaprio it's at least think me
I was good and Leonardo DiCaprio was a
good gatsby crap he was you know who's a
good gatsby but was he a Great Gatsby
oh I don't know it sounds pretty goofy
saying stuff like old sport and
everybody sounds goofy saying old sport
even people that lived in the 20s ound
goofy saying old sport but like the
whole point that's a pretty stupid
reason to write own book did you at
least find the movie visually
stimulating in any way
I'm yes but found Prometheus visually
stimulating that just found the story to
be a snoozer Great Gatsby the film may
look pretty right but the story is
cosmic Peppa's a model team you can't
blame the director for the story I can
blame him for choosing to adapt this
book into a movie yeah it certainly can
no one put a gun to his head I thought
it was great okay and when you like
Moulin Rouge a lot of people like Moulin
Rouge well a lot of people are stupid
you don't have a lot of friends do you
listen the movie score just the peanut
until jay-z shows up and pulls you right
out of the time period that's a
stylistic choice
all right I thought it was badass
jay-z's a lot like Gatsby actually hunt
racist no it's not looking why didn't
you just accept the fact that some books
are unfilmable listen Life of Pi was
supposed to be unfilmable right and then
Angley came along and won an Oscar for
it Richard Baca I just walked right into
that one didn't I
you